[Music]
is that a great new pepsi can or what
if like me you cannot believe that cindy
crawford's original pepsi ad aired
almost 30 years ago you're gonna love
this so the supermodel is throwing it
back to the 1992 ad for a really great
cause
posting a photo to her instagram
crawford poses in front of the famous
halfway house cafe wearing the same
white tank top denim shorts and silver
hoops she rocked in the iconic ad now
she captioned the photo we returned back
to the original halfway house from the
famous pepsi commercial i did in 1992 to
recreate the moment with a david yarrow
twist in hopes of raising funds for the
american family children's hospital in
madison wisconsin where my brother was
treated for leukemia
the best part aside from the fact that
cindy crawford doesn't seem to age her
recreation has already raised one
million dollars for the children's
hospital adding i think we nailed it
such a fun day i can't wait to show you
more
and it's not just her fans who are
excited for more some of cindy's famous
friends have commented as well with
reese witherspoon writing truly gorgeous
and for a great cause helena christensen
added cool in every way and tyra banks
shared what we're all thinking when i
fell in love with the legend of crawford
you